you're uh
you're not haven't been inducted to the
hall of fame yet
is that correct but but this is a
guarantee you're the greatest of all
time
okay thank you i'm not sure about that
there's a lot of guys that can claim the
to be the the goat uh it's very
subjective
as you know to say that
but but yeah i'm i'm inducted to the
hall of fame but they
the party has not happened yet because
they announced it but they didn't made
it they made it official but they didn't
really make the
the the celebration okay that comes with
it well congratulations on
being a hall of famer man that's awesome
and
thank you man thank you very few people
are in the conversation about the
greatest of all time right i mean who
are we talking about you hear
jon jones gsp could be
khabib ah anderson silva
i understand what i would say i think
fedor magnalenko the problem i think
guys is
that there's some of them that
could be in the conversation but they
stay and hang out
way too long past their prime in the
sport so they kind of
tarnish their legacy unfortunately yeah
i think that when i think about uh
silva or andre are live and
you know they could have retired on top
and being like the
like the goat but unfortunately they
ain't there too long
and that's a problem that makes perfect
sense
and uh i was going to say the same thing
about anderson silva i feel like
you know who who's on your list for the
goat
well there's a few uh it depends for
which reason
if you talk about the guy who made the
who change their sport change martial
art my number one goat is
royce gracie yeah he's for me the best
of all time because he have done stuff
in his poorest time that i believe will
never be repeated
however if you ask me if i would put
rice gracie in
the ufc right now against the the
the fighters of that era i don't think
he would do well
but for his era he was the best he was
the best of all time
i believe the best the best fighters is
not even born yet
because recorders are made to be broken
if you talk about who's
legit legitimately the the real goat i
don't think he's born yet because
the fighters of today are better than
the one of yesterday
and the one of tomorrow as good as they
are today
as good as they are they will be better
in the future
and if you don't believe me just because
fighting is a very subjective thing
there is no instrument of measure just
look at track and field
uh weightlifting uh like the sport that
you can measure
we always talk about oh who's better
tyson noeli or lebron james or michael
jordan or this guy
i believe the most generally speaking
the more
the most recent athletes are always
better not because they're better
person because they have access to
better technology and knowledge
okay well i think that if uh if physical
appearance
was a factor then then you win
you are gorgeous you're the goat for the
best looking ufc fighter
of all time i'm not sure about that
i think another another uh actually all
kidding aside
important criteria should be your
outside of the octagon life right like i
mean
as far as you don't have anything
tarnishing your legacy
for outside of fighting and
that's good
look look i've done a lot of crazy i've
done a lot of crazy [ __ ] you know like
like
like don't get wrong i i enjoyed my life
i i
you know i was a i had access of to
things that
that most people don't i i party a lot
i made a lot of i had a lot of fun and i
enjoyed it uh
you know what i mean i've done all my
crazy stuff and i feel good you know
why would i would fight for if i would
not have if it would not be
to enjoy it it's i don't fight because i
enjoy to fight i
i fight because of the life that it
gives me the freedom that it provides me
and of course i did a lot of crazy stuff
the problem is i know how to keep it
down i know how to keep it secret
they go out party and they they lose
their mind and then you know that's a
problem you know
i have a suspicion i'm by no mean
a monk right you know i party a lot i
have a lot of fun i didn't do it
like i i didn't cross certain lines you
know i did not but
but i had a lot of fun like yeah of
course like some people they think yeah
i always follow a diet and this i don't
drink yeah it's not true i i enjoyed my
life
and and and my answer is like why would
i would
why would i would fight all this time
and add that that
career that that crazy career if i if i
couldn't enjoy it
the benefits of it you know what i mean
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon and buy stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude